with November dominated by the likes of
Call of Duty and Assassin's Creed it
falls to October to give us some lesser
known or at least commercially colossal
gaming gems and boy did we get a gaming
gem this October Platinum Games as
Bayonetta 2 will long be remembered as
an absolute classic the kind of game
that's worth splurging on a new system
for it took everything that was great
about its predecessor gave it a lick of
colorful Wii U paint and then upped the
crazy to wonderful New Heights few games
are as madc from the outset as B at a
two within moments of hitting start
you're hurtling towards the Earth the
top a crumbling slap of building
fighting glittering Golden Angels and
then minutes later you're on a jet
fighter firing guns from your feet and
laying bloody Wast to horse riding
jousters with wings the action rarely
lets up each boss battle and set piece
escalating towards a climax of Epic
Proportions all backed by a control
system and field that sets The Benchmark
for Action game combat finish bayetta 2
and you'll want to play it through again
increasing the difficulty to master each
one of bayonetta's gruesome yet elegant
Combos and to unlock some of the
wonderful Nintendo Easter eggs Bayonetta
2 is a game that must be experienced and
even if you have to beg steal or borrow
to get a Wii U to play it on trust me
it's more than worth
it